[Music]
i feel like that was our worst game yet
probably not
probably by a lot but agreed i'm gonna
play queen takes d4
okay this is the allen p show move that
he's played against me in all of the
banter blitz sessions
yeah so e5 knights i i'm just gonna
trust
yeah but he was always playing it
differently whoa kingside castle
yeah half sam explain is what if i take
anyway principal i've been crediting you
in my uh educational explanations for
that
like what happens if i do it anyway i
feel like that's that's your one of your
many contributions yeah yes like if you
have a key positional idea that you're
trying to accomplish and your opponent
is stopping you from doing so first
question you should always ask yourself
is what happens if i do it anyway
uh i claimed this was my contribution to
chess and then jacob said i was a
plagiarizer and that he came up with it
first
uh but i don't know i don't know i've
i've credited you i hope
yaakov will be okay with that uh i call
this the
principal he's not gonna be okay with it
and that just makes me so much happier
all right what is this do you want
tonight's coming to c4
let's let's make a very slow this one
very subtle
yeah no dude i wasn't sure what you were
preparing there no but i hate these
structures
let's normally for white
i remember i had this against mac mulner
and i offered him a draw in a lost
position and he took it in riga
i see yeah great story f4 is a good move
actually
yeah no it is it's definitely best but
um
i'm not wildly dissatisfied with my
position either
are we gonna handle this though
um yes
let's just take it it's probably i was
i'm not sure maybe i had a better move
but
they work out for him obviously sure
but there's some jersey ideas yeah
and what are they could they consist of
what if i sack exchange
should be safe enough right i don't know
i feel like
it just looks like white's doing well
but
it does but looks can be deceiving i
mean you look like a smart guy
i mean
i saw uh you know mrs shanklin looks
like a smackdown
is that supposed to be my mother or my
non-existent wife
[Laughter]
i mean you fill in the blank
no this is uh that was bad though no
it's all good it was unoriginal
what we're here for all right but no i
think i've been totally outplayed once
more
um
shoot i have been totally outplayed do
you remember when
my mom dropped me off at us chess league
in like 2006 and i was telling you all
about who had
who had a crush on i don't remember that
you were threatening me with like
telling my mom
would she really care oh defense i don't
know we passed the
russian test did we did you have a crush
on the wrong person
i mean not really so i mean sort of
all right okay fine i think uh i have a
crush on my own position here
all right make counter play and hope for
the best
serious counterplay yeah okay
so i guess i gotta take this
here i don't bite
not not one bit yeah yeah
i'm just busted yeah all right i'm
wasting everyone's time let's play again
well played
thank you all right let's go back to d4
this night or
it was fun but even though i was getting
good positions i'm not thrilled with how
i was playing
let's play queens indian okay
i think this is what boris does right
yeah i don't know i've just sort of
played this you're getting like left or
something
oh here i think yeah because i haven't
castled yet
i think this was boris's big point ah
but wait isn't there like 94
yeah and down in 1964 and you're
slightly worse if i were oh
wow this was boris's big foreign
yeah um
he was playing like this but they have
to be a little bit careful because of e3
you got five and they takes d4 so i
think i have to play queen d2 here from
one
second
so f5 knight c3
d5 is interesting
yeah i can see why this is unpleasant
okay i have an idea if i go here it's
hoping you wouldn't see that i just
wanted this completely
but is it actually so easy if you take
there is quincy too
here first now oh shoot that's a good
move
damn damn you're so tricky even when you
play bad openings i'm just lost in like
three moves
he sees everything okay but
okay i'm much worse here but i'm not
done i'm not known for my technique
sure
all right so i gotta try something yeah
okay i'll go here i was thinking maybe i
could show you foreigner
wow
b4984 huh this was my idea i mean i'm
probably just in big trouble one way or
another but here
yeah i'm just going to just double on
the f5
start with this
yeah i see what you're doing here i've
got to throw something and hope for the
best
from blundering pawns left and right
all right
this doesn't seem that easy yeah i
agreed
okay i'm gonna tie you down
that's a good enough all right so
uh quincy five take take ninety four
bad news yeah yeah or even 94.94 is a
small threat
um
[ __ ] how did this get bad yeah
is 94 actually a threat well 94 queen
for rock f2
queen f2 and rook f6 yeah oh yeah that's
even stronger uh
this is bad news um
all right quirky one hope for the best
yeah
let me get it come over here and then
ricofade and rookie too and
hope for a miracle all right
keep on hoping feels like a flimsy
strategy but it's better than nothing
that i didn't think was great because of
queen c5 i
saw this oh man
you suck dead bunnies
any reason to keep playing this game
not really right i mean all right
ah you're killing me daniel all right
come back start lucky
okay let's go all right let's play
another bishop
okay e5 is sort of a thing i guess
let's put the queen somewhere a little
different this time
and i will amend my strategy to this
move
okay so i'll try to go after you here
yeah it's a good [ __ ]
now if i castle i don't think i got
enough sorry i gotta
play castle i mean i couldn't take any
seven there
why not okay ah rookie one bishop f1
there
roman rookie eight yeah that's probably
too much i should have just castled
oh well no but this is still [ __ ]
good
i don't think this is so bad though you
put the wrong rook on d1 to tear my head
off right
yeah i'm trying to get the other hook in
the game but a4 okay three just doesn't
seem like
enough okay i'm just gonna come come
this
so
so let's start with brick submit
okay now i can castle
okay just make some small improvements
sure
i never know what to do here yeah not in
easy position
um
somehow it's hard to even make a
reasonable move right
now that pawn is just going well i can
play knight c5 and a few
if you put b4 on me you're going to
weaken the c3 right
now i'll take it try to make some
trouble here
okay let's get out of there
oh crap is that a mouse flip yeah yeah
i'll resign that's
that's all right i can is there a way to
take back no no no no
i won't allow it that's part of the game
that's gonna be the game that turns it
around so you're gonna regret that later
on
we'll see we'll see all right let's try
something else to check
yeah yeah this is dangerous it's gonna
be dangerous okay
i don't know if i'm supposed to do this
so soon but yeah i don't know this at
all
i mean i know somebody i play this with
white
yeah but sorry here i'm saying
so bishop e3 knight g4 is probably okay
for you right
yeah i think so but if i play f3 do you
have any tricks
queen b6 or something it's close f3
um it looks very i think i remember this
actually you're supposed to take and
then after bc i have c5 yeah but i'm
gonna play with the bishop
okay sure but now i get them roxy you do
but okay i have two bishops how bad is
this for black i never really
was afraid of this slightly worse it's
not that bad my track record of beating
you in slightly worse
it's not particularly good okay let's go
here okay
who saw my trick what a shocker stop
being 95.
all right so let's start by attacking
this fellow
okay
interesting
i don't know what i'm doing let's have
some fun okay
shall we all right so cb and then knight
cb5 you have some
queen b6 is your plan i thought just
green did
i mean there's a couple things i thought
queen d2
bishop d2 i don't believe let's see
queen b6
what do you have there nb6 probably a4
e5 and that's bad news right yeah but a4
even bishop b5
let's see okay hang on i gotta find some
way to cause trouble but i don't
uh what a troll um
you're not supposed to be able to get
this move so easily but i don't see how
to punish you for it
all right i see an idea that looks at
least interesting
so let's try it okay
i have uh-huh idea what's going on this
probably just doesn't work but at least
it looks interesting
all right well it does i'll move my rook
away okay
okay okay could us
seems pretty unclear to me yeah
definitely messy
and then i might just be lost but it's
not going to be easy no no no i think
it's not so clear
it's not easy for you to play this that
i have all these ideas
i need to record next sir
should i or shouldn't i
i feel like that's topical all right to
be honest i just completely missed that
that's okay
this is not going to work is it i don't
believe
all right what's up queen h6
and uh yeah that knight under seven
is the hero all right
let's touch stuff okay let's go with
another default
okay shall we repeat that i'm happy to
i'm gonna get to see
with a hell of a lot more time this time
that's right all right
so here here
here 94.
okay f4 is not supposed to be a great
move i'm pretty sure
i'll all right repeat it here
i think i took here all right so
[Music]
this feels like yourself try to improve
um
let's see but i'm not gonna spend way
too much time looking for the miracle
so this last one was let's try c5 again
and i'm going to be
okay a bit more proactive this time
well what did i do here i think i went
last time i played b4 like
okay cd seems like a much more
intelligent move
hmm okay
very tempted to play a5 and then hope
for some sort of prayer with
knight c7 yeah i think i don't know why
i was so scared of hxb5 it's clear that
a5 check was the actual threat
all right okay i'm gonna do it
all right so okay six
okay now i need to think
i'm pretty happy here yeah yeah it just
doesn't seem like there's much
i agree okay let's evacuate
okay so d3
yeah i don't like this one [ __ ]
sure that's actually a really annoying
move
i just blunder the game away in one move
i'm
pretty sure there must be something here
and you can try this but this is not
really glorious
in fact it just looks bad but
calculating
my big point was my df6 here but
i didn't see that at all actually i'm
scared or trying yeah
wow that's a pretty cool but now i'm
just going to take
check take bishop g2 you have here
and am i busted here or something right
you like it
you should start falling out
okay well i'm have to take all right is
this the end of the world i don't think
you're going to make me i have a pretty
good bond
that is true i'm going to try though
okay so i guess you're threatening
queen to see it
after yep which i have to be pretty
careful about
you and your nefarious tricks
it's hard to prevent
yeah all right so i guess i'm playing
queen here which is not a good sign but
bishop okay now i'm gonna go
this one here i thought queen of three
queen c7 and
hope for the best yeah scary but i don't
see a win for you and someday these
pawns are gonna be good
someday yeah maybe not today but
no pretty soon
might grab my pants here okay rookie six
yeah rick d6 you have for other
reptilian one but i don't really care
so that was the idea that now my king
gets there yeah i didn't
i forgot about that but i was already
too late that's my idea okay but now
sam i'm going to give you a check again
and
here and then
check there
i had all this worked out in advance
completely oh but i missed that move
too good don't feel too good online
player
yeah all right show me online technique
okay with pleasure
ah that's looks like it finishes the
game pretty fast
okay
okay
all right he got it you're good daniel
too good that was close
you must have been busted there well
skeptic thanks yeah
all right what do you do against the
baltic
this even has a name i think i'm
supposed to take this
careful yeah so this i'm just trying to
remember there's some tricks so it's
like takens now
you have to be careful not to get the
rook trapped but if i recall you're
supposed to
start with knight f3 and then it's like
e3 and i have to go bishop d2 next i
think is the point
so i'm just going to go e5
this one i thought i could b4 b5 am i
not no
i don't know i actually don't know
really i don't know a thing but this
looks
at least like fun let's have some fun
and usually to find a way to make a draw
here but
hilarious clever daniel i've always been
known for my humor
okay you know what sam we're gonna take
this guy
okay so we should do two and then what
happens
i don't see miss this move it
this might be a miniature i'm pretty
sure bishop d2 is like always the best
move in all of these positions
yeah well now i have to basically go for
this like kind of position
but this should be horrible for you well
at least i can give you a check though
yeah but how much do i care
um thank you dragovich
how bad is this actually
you have blitz tricks right
sorry i almost played knight shoot five
there oh god
it's pretty bad oh man not my day all
right still going
five sure maybe now i can play knight g5
yeah i'm skeptical but
why exactly
okay i probably should have just played
rookie one like an adult
but uh i'm gonna go here
so you have some evil trick take take d3
is
kind of annoying right right
what if i grab the pawn oh
sam
playing like a very aggressive player
i've played this so badly that's it's
all good
what do i do it's got to be something
this bishop on c5 is not going to
checkmate me
no it's not that is a true statement
oh okay
[ __ ] okay i gotta think
hmm
crazy idea but there's no way this works
i can't find a thing okay fine
very surprised ourselves in there
yeah i'm not sure i mean i just
get the rook to the open file right yeah
i had an idea here though
okay yeah it's i'm sure it doesn't work
but
for blitz
couldn't see exactly what you're doing
here you know
try this
but you're right you've made this more
complicated than i thought you were
going to be able to
but isn't this just completely lost off
for queen d3
maybe it's not so easy and if i go queen
a4 am i mating you
probably it's like f4 welcome to my
world
ah that was your trick
that was the big idea so g4 and we're
guessing something
you rascal
let's look whatever i do it's very
tricky
but i think i think i'm evaporating
in fact i got this one
in the bag you see i'm not bad but it's
never
in the bag with you but i think i will
survive this
okay so wait a minute let's throw this
one in
all right please just be my guest i have
bishop f5
you piece
f4 push this guy through still some
ah that's your big idea so bishop takes
d2 and then what
check and bishop f4
queen c3 rook t3
h2 i think you're out of steam okay
yeah nicely done well defended okay that
was a fun game that was a great game
all right let's keep playing this uh
rouser because
um i don't give up easily enough
all right so that's a6
i just thought these positions were sort
of okay for black even if you get d4
okay
i don't know anything here something
like this
i think i'm supposed to do this right
lopez maneuver
yeah but it's not so easy
is this your thing here i don't know i
mean open some stuff
up to have some fun yeah no i probably
should have
not allowed that all right
i'll check your word for it
yeah i think i'm supposed to start with
rook fv8 there you're right
right because he did a lot of a lot of
ideas
yeah how bad is this
it's actually not i'm gonna try to play
this in a more measured way than usual
yeah i mean i'm a little worse here for
sure but i don't think it's still
thank you for the five gifted appreciate
it man you're reading the chat while
kicking my ass
i'm just i'm thinking the sub i'm
thinking subs but i'm basically not
reading the chat
okay just be like big sub sub uh gifts
yeah okay let's go here
yeah this has been misplayed by yours
truly
all right bishop f3 it's not pretty but
i
kind of have to yeah you do
this is a very ugly position
okay so bishop e5 95 it's bad for me
this is what we're going to do
it's a nasty little move isn't it yeah i
saw it
talking what was i supposed to do i
didn't see a move
try to liquidate a little bit let's
challenge this queen
all right let her make up her mind and
then
play it from there okay
and there's so many you're forcing me to
a decision
okay let's take with the bishop that's a
good move but i thought here maybe i
could play 95
yeah now maybe here
all right knight d5 and then what's the
big idea
i don't like it when you say that
yeah i'm probably losing in one move but
i don't see it
i feel like i i don't understand your
idea right now
what if i think it was kind of
wait but now i just uh oh 25.
all right too good
okay let's try c4 maybe
this will trick you let's try this
system
all right what's this supposed to be yes
knight f3 34
and now i think a 94.
i thought that was supposed to be best
but
what do i know um
let's just start with take this
yeah i think this is a good setup you
put in the wood yeah i didn't know
you're probably a little worse here but
you know the routine you're always a
little worse i'm always that prepared
i'm a little better and then you win the
game that's what you do
indeed oh man i'm not whining enough i
told myself before this match i need to
throw a massive temper tantrum whenever
and i've not done a very good leave that
to me
all right have you ever played anyone
who's thrown like a temper tantrum
like a gm i mean tantrum is a strong
word
i've thrown i've played people who have
not behaved well after the game
uh but it's i don't they don't behave
like hostilely they like
right they're not being disrespectful
they're just clearly upset and not
channeling their disappointment in a
very constructive way but like
i can't remember anybody just like oh my
god you're such a lucky jackass or
whatever
i don't remember this kind of thing
happening particularly often even when
like i was quite a bit younger and
playing stronger guys um right
so i don't know okay let's go
now
okay i'm gonna make it interesting that
is an interesting move
it's very dubious is everything you do
yeah i thought queen d6 yeah but i know
i thought i'd take and go
rugby too yeah this is a little annoying
here right
uh and then i'm not gonna have such an
easy time finishing the game off
uh my bishop is not very good but i
think you
you're still clearly up on down and you
have to prove it definitely
sure
so if f5 where does your bishop go oh
[ __ ]
god damn it ah come on man you're
kicking my ass every game i can
you can have one win just look through
the cracks
but yeah all right so
let's see that's not a very good bishop
shut up okay let's start by
letting you
go e5 seems fine
okay wait a minute
there's really nothing i can do wait
what if i
ah bishop before oh this was my plan
yeah okay is this
forced made or close rook d8
uh you're so tricky dude so tricky
i'm sorry i'm a one-trick pony though
that's all i have
no class so
that's a good move though isn't it still
kicking
yeah oh it's never easy this year all
right so
check it's thinking maybe e6 just wins
the game
on the spot looks pretty good
um okay so rookie rookie 47
f67 yeah i think it's over
oh not just df that's supposed to work
yeah nicely done thank you
i'm not getting embarrassed at least
even if i'm
playing badly 6
all right so you've tricked me into a
night off when i've been playing the
rouser
right exactly uh that's okay so what is
this
i don't have a thing yeah i don't
remember anything either
i think i'm supposed to go here actually
do you not care about night shift yeah
that's the point yeah this is right i
had actually ortiz played
artsy is franklin ortiz famous game yeah
this one
you inspired me to play h4 i played it
and quickly got a horrible possession
but you won i did it i remember i
remember looking at that game
like please win so you get validated
yeah
okay
you're a brave man indeed all right
i i am a man in pursuit of fun
let's go let's go
thanks for the sub so
i think i have to start with the smooth
maybe
i'll take this
so i feel like i'm not supposed to let
that bishop stay in here but
um let's take this
here yeah am i just gonna get mated in
three moves or something that's the plan
so i guess i take that edge
yeah man you make mating the dragon
looks so easy
the night off i mean well
i don't know what i have though that's
in a really nice actually not that clear
i mean
i'm gonna take it though okay so i guess
my king out of dodge
i don't think i had another move there
no that's first
i'm pretty sure it's forced but this has
to be made somehow
it has to but those are dangerous words
you know
yes let me think
how about this one i was talking about
that but i wasn't sure what the
follow-up was
yeah just sort of seeing what you want
to do
36 i guess
jesus such a psychopath
wait bishop g5 queen e5 queen g5
um that's 25 pins
so strong daniel's so strong thank you
thank you
i was going to take on f6 first and go
to d6 so there you've got queen e7
and i did it to myself because of i put
my bishop on e6 yeah right
oh boy okay
just hope to complicate
but i don't think i will manage hmm
yeah wait a second
i think just takes seems good enough
right f4 take that one
unfortunately you found the right book
to take all right
all right
okay this f1 is going to win the game
okay so i think it is going to be
slightly difficult for me to come back
at this point
yeah what do we have 10 minutes left
13 more minutes yeah
i knew there's no way i was gonna hold
it together this much but
um no games have been very fun i think
but i think uh more points than i was
expecting to have at this point
you're underrated my friends
okay what if i just grab it it's hoping
that i could pretend to have some
initiative here but
maybe it just does
better than the air things thanks akilah
okay we'll take sure
let you go after me
that is a nefarious move
okay man you're asking for it
i am but all right so let's see queen d5
and what the hell do you have
who idea knight f3
iii queen g3 king f1
now you have a lot of pawns at the very
least actually d5 i think have something
better
all right
i guess i should play cd5
yeah but now oh you little freaking
yeah i can play for stupid tricks too
but now here yes and now i'm just busted
once more
yeah yeah i believe so
well let's see if i can make any kind of
a fight it's old chap
that's going to go very far remember
it's just like my gaming is leo martinez
he's just leak
text
yeah but notice this yeah that's pretty
good isn't it
it is let's go ahead
oh that's neat all right
too good daniel too good let's try this
all right
i think this is what i was playing at
the world's cup
i think this is supposed to be like
quite okay for me because you have
already castles
oh so you don't you don't cancel
well there's some line where you get
like rook g1 and g4 g5 and because you
have already castled this d3 system is
not very dangerous but
but aren't you just worse here like a
little bit i'm gonna sack the pun
i mean i think you and i have so far as
i think i was just taking it from you
okay let's go here all right fair enough
doug you bear thanks okay so i guess i
should stop you from
letting d4 you want to play it anyway
i suppose that makes sense yeah
75 hmm
maybe here first get out of here
yeah so
bishop
i might take with the pawn if you take
it
well i will all right
i believed you there for a second i said
i might i didn't say i would
young now fought ideas
marduk thanks sure
okay fine i gotta try it
d7
i find it so hard to believe that i'm
gonna get killed here but
i don't believe you well you have a way
of surprising me
yeah i'm just gasping for breath though
i need to some create some sort of
chances here
it's a very nice night on h1 this is
like a textbook
position actually i'm gonna improve it
though okay
so want to take that not really
it's fine let's bring a rook to b2
no you won't my knight is gonna have
something to say about that
okay oh bishop b3 rugby t3 dirty
i learn from the best i play for tricks
all right
so rook b2 knight d5 am i scared
maybe a little bit better that's right
and then if i see and then you have
bishop b3 that's a little annoying
actually
um let's start with c4
d4 huh knight c6
i've missed i don't know how you always
make chances i mean i'm probably still
winning here but it's so much
messier than it was a second ago right
now i'm feeling pretty decent about this
yeah i've just played this once more
i don't see really
i think
whoa fireworks
my state right
so i don't believe it you'll have to
educate me
and you're telling me queen h6 is
actually going to meet me
yep that's what i'm saying sam so rick
g2 queen h6
queen f6 and what the hell take
take you take my rook and then not easy
so
if i start with queen f6 here you resign
or do i miss something
i'll start with resign
who do you think i am a gentleman
but
it's the tricks tricks
wait i have no time how did that happen
um
scary stuff ah
[Music]
come on
no i've gotten hopeful
all right
it are you just getting away from me
here
ah jesus how did i lose that game
all right do we have time for one more
before i can uh sure
not much after this horrible game
absolutely all right
that was so painful i was absolutely
fine
this is not supposed to be good it's
like terrible
so here and down here yeah
and now like i don't get your play at
all
okay in the spirit of
finest traditions
i already just like worse against the
troll opening i feel like
oh boy not my day
okay i'm gonna spice it up though okay
how exactly
all right let's go
i'm good at boring
just don't underestimate that skill
oh knight a2 jesus water everything had
to play three or something and i was
much better
yeah stop now
okay now
oh boy
let's see frequency three
if i swindle you in this last game that
would be karmic justice
rook d8 bishop h7 queen h that's it
that's what i was hoping for
well you're too fast
how bad is this for me i don't think
it's bad actually
i mean i'm worse but am i busted i don't
believe so actually
i don't even know if you're worse
to be completely honest with you
you know what i'm going to do
prophylaxis
king out of the kill zone yeah yeah
seems sensible just looks
um
all right let's start breaking it while
we're all playing bourgeois prophylactic
chest
right okay
what going on here
okay that's one but now you can't play
knight c3 anymore so can't i take h5
i can't play knight c3 yeah but what is
the threat now
okay i thought i have just like this
um so queen ed shades knight g6 king
f6 and you somehow just live i believe
that's really depressing
but even f takes g6 and bishop f7 and
then queen e5
and now you still you live there as well
okay so you to do what you got to do
that's the end all right daniel good
match
thank you thank you i know it's you know
too strong this is all i do so at least
you didn't beat me two to one
yeah no i mean a lot of fun games this
was
awesome i had a blast and um
yeah thanks for making time sam it's
yeah i know we're friends but it's it's
an honor
i wish i could have challenged you a bit
more uh honest question i'm not trying
to be a sore loser or anything i'm
genuinely curious about your opinion
uh do you think you would i think it's
pretty clear i scored better than what i
just did if we play face to face over
the board
do you think you still beat me though
over the board three plus zero
yeah i think probably fifty percent
three plus two
i i think i would say three plus zero
maybe slight favor three plus two
close to fifty percent maybe you're a
favorite what do you think no i think
fifty percent
yeah that sounds about right i mean i'm
not a great blitz player in general
uh this much we've all known but uh
well classical is where it's better yeah
now when classical returns i'm hoping
that'll be the glorious comeback and
i don't know sam sam was mad at me
because i didn't trash talk enough but
uh yeah yeah this was a lot of fun so
yeah thanks to eric and thanks to daniel
for playing and thanks to all of
daniel's fans for supporting this match
and uh
hope you all enjoyed it thank you sam
it's again
it's really an honor that was a lot of
fun let's do it do it again
i'll let you uh have a have a great
evening sam thank you so much
my pleasure have a good one all right
you too sam
[Music]